pour nous au nom c'était très facile et
on nous a dit qu'il fallait se vacciner
on a dit ok et séquencer où cette mère
d'un garçon de huit semaines fait partie
du groupe pas si nombreux des
québécoises qui ont accepté avec
enthousiasme de se faire vacciner contre
halak au vide pendant leur grossesse le
fait que vous soyez enceinte ne rien
changer votre décision de feu avec ce
n'est lui ça a changé je la
voulais parce que j'ai pas 12 mois c'est
la petite qu'il faut faut prendre soin
d'elle à l'opt à saint justin c'est
souvent la situation contraire que les
professionnels rencontrent au moins 30 %
des patientes ne seraient pas vaccinés
je peux parler de saint justin et aussi
du reste du québec là mes collègues me
relis relais la même chose que ce que je
constate sur le terrain c'est à dire que
beaucoup de femmes enceintes hésitent à
se faire vacciner encore actuellement
c'est le cas de cette dame qui attend
son deuxième enfant pour moi oui surtout
qu'il n'a pas vraiment d'études sur ça
on n'a pas beaucoup d'informations sur
sa décision est prise dit elle pas
question de changer de vie et qu'est ce
que vous dit votre médecin il me
conseille de prendre même un massage
préfère attendre après après la rochelle
selon la santé publique depuis qu'elles
sont admissibles en avril dernier à
peine onze mille femmes enceintes ont
reçu une double dose de vaccin contre
halak au vide il 15000 une seule dose
alors que normalement plus de 40 mais le
petit québécois naissent par tranche de
six mois pourtant ne pas être vexé ni
peut avoir des conséquences graves on
sait très bien maintenant c'est
clairement démontré que faire la queue
vite quand on est enceinte c'est plus
sérieux ça augmente le risque
d'hospitalisation à peu près par par
quatre et le risque de création en soin
intensif par 11 aux états unis depuis le
début de la pandémie vingt-deux mille
femmes enceintes ont été hospitalisés et
160 et une sont décédés
97% d'entre elles n'avait reçu aucune
dose de vaccin
les spécialistes se reconnaît cependant
qu'il est normal et sain de se
questionner durant une grossesse est
tout à fait logique les femmes enceintes
et leurs familles devaient faire le
meilleur choix pour pour leurs bébés et
à nous médecins praticiens en santé
c'est à notre rôle de les guider dans ce
choix et leur donner les bonnes
informations
au début j'avais un titre est ce parce
que justement le vaccin venait de sortir
en mai dernier cette jeune femme a pris
son temps elle s'est informée il de
suivi j'ai parlé avec mon docteur et
puis pour moi le risque était vraiment
plus important au niveau de la cage vide
au niveau d'avoir un accouchement
prématuré plus avoir des grosses
complications donc la tk main une
décision relativement facile faut jouer
les bonnes informations ici normal
rondins radio canada montréal